glück muss man haben in zürich oder viel
geld
wer keine genossenschaftswohnung findet
oder keine städtische wohnung muss tief
in die tasche greifen wer kann sich
diese stadt eigentlich noch leisten
kein wunder dass es in zürich zu solchen
szenen kommt 5000 menschen wollen
städtische wohnungen an der kronen wie
sie besichtigen weil die mieten dort
nicht zu hoch sind wie auf dem freien
markt unter die und bürger derby und als
ich sagt sie wir harry potter hat der
neue warum
der zürcher wohnungsmarkt anscheinend
geschlossen für normalverdiener mirela
lief sucht 500 zimmer für sich ihren
mann und die drei kinder
fünfeinhalb zimmer die bezahlbar sind
für menschen mit normalem einkommen kein
luxus nichts besonderes einfach nur
zusammenleben an dem ort an dem man
leben will
zürich und der wohnungsmarkt das ist die
schattenseite einer lebenswerten
metropole hier in der europaallee muss
ich mir relativ erst gar nicht bewerben
ein städtebauliches prestige-projekt
hohe mieten luxus wohnungen büros das
zerrbild einer modernen stadt
der architekt und stadtplaner ernst
huberty kritisiert diese entwicklung und
die stadtpolitik die seines erachtens
nur zuschauen zu wenig eingreifen ist
eigentlich typisch frau für zürich
insofern dass stadt erlaubt hat bei
maximal ausbauvolumen zu realisieren
der dow theorie wenig theorie büros und
wenn man das resultat deckt damit sagen
sich es geht wie viel verdienen
entstanden
alkoholiker wo insofern denen urbani
triste auslöst
die werke holik treffen sich nur selber
es gibt keine chiquita vielfalt
überraschung also bahn erhalte aber viel
lebendiger gegen diese entwicklung
protestiert seit 2013 die initiative wem
gehört zügig eine protestbewegung gegen
die verdrängung die durch hohe mieten
auf dem freien wohnungsmarkt entsteht
mitbegründet von betroffenen wieder
statt forscherin wesner tom vaagt dann
sind alle vier zerstörte müsli foto
schlange und findet so was mache ich
jetzt
und wenn zeit ist bis der herr gemacht
dass musiker zusammenschlüsse dass man
lösungsvorschlag verschiedene lösungen
sind dringend notwendig in zürich soll
wie alle städte wachsen und die
zersiedelung der agglomeration
aufzuhalten
das ist der politische wille doch um
welchen preis
vor zwölf jahren musste auch mirela lief
raus aus zürich ausland ziehen mit ihrem
mann dem künstler titus meier ihren
söhnen am idee und den er und nevis
ihrer tochter mit drei kindern war das
leben wohnen und arbeiten in der stadt
zu teuer geworden
nun hat sich die lebenssituation
verändert die kinder sind groß die
schulwege lang und mirja arbeitet wieder
in der stadt
das problem ist dass das jeder andere
note oder und es ist eigentlich dass man
als familie das miteinander verbringen
und wohnen
das machen sich gesehen und dann jeder
wieder haben die teile die von dir gott
das ist geglückt
doch wo findet man fünfeinhalb zimmer
bezahlbar halbwegs zentral
an den rändern der stadt wo massiv
gebaut wird wo architektonische
künstlichkeit auf soziale kälte trifft
enden die wohnträume bei viereinhalb
zimmer genauso im zentrum wo so
verdichtet gebaut wird dass die sonne
kaum eine wohnung hilft hier bringen
fünf zimmer zu wenig gewesen
was bleibt sind städtische wohnung
denn in zürich muss nach einem
volksentscheid ein drittel aller
mietwohnungen gemeinnützig also
bezahlbar sei wie will die stadt dieses
ehrgeizige ziel erreichen stadt
investiert nach langer zeit sehr stark
und damit der nutzer schafft es immerhin
eigentliche erneuerungsprozess über das
angebot an einmütige honige sehr stark
viele genossenschaften renovieren ihre
in die jahre gekommenen immobilien
bleiben sie dennoch der garant für
billiges wohnen ganz große player
kostengünstige
alltag bei der wohnungssuche auch bei
genossenschaften fragt mir relativ nach
auch hier ist die antwort meist negativ
im moment geöffnet heißt es vernichtend
zukunft die antworten sind austauschbar
hier zeigt sich das paradox das dilemma
von städten wie zürich die menschen die
die stadt lebendig machen
urban und lebenswert die dienstleister
die kreativen wie die goldschmiedin
mirela lief sie dürfen hier arbeiten
doch wohnen müssen sie woanders